Rina and Maya D were shot dead in the
West Bank on their way to a family
holiday in Lake Galilee 10 days ago
they were in the car with their mother
Lucy when Palestinian terrorists opened
fire and forced their car off the road
their father and siblings were further
up the road ahead of them
I called Lucy no answer I called Maya no
answer I called really no answer then
you know we were slightly panicking at
this point and I looked on Google family
link and I found that they were at the
camera Junction and that seemed to be
where this big girl was this attack was
um
and my son I think received on a website
for attacks in Israel because
unfortunately there is such a site a
photograph of the car just the car and
we spotted our suitcases in it covered
in blood
the Friday night of this hack I was in
the hospital and I had nightmares and
then I woke up and then my reality was
worse than nightmare so I went back to
sleep and then I had another nightmare
and all I could picture was the moment
of the crash
and the terrorists and the bullets and
uh
that's like a picture
Lucy was airlifted to hospital outside
Jerusalem but died three days later her
organs were donated and have already
saved the lives of five people one of
them an Arab Israeli I think that is
significant to us because Lucy was very
much into uh you know peaceful relations
with our neighbors and I think she would
have been very proud that she saved a
life of an Arab even in this situation
thousands of people from across Israel
and the world have come to pay respects
at the family shiver the seven day
period of mourning in the Jewish faith
the Israeli Prime Minister binim
Netanyahu was leaving in a military
helicopter as we arrived
Rabbi D says that he believes a letter
of condolence sent to him by the British
foreign secretary James cleverley is a
landmark moment for British Israeli
relations
I feel that that statement saying that
Britain stands unequivocally against
Violence Against Terror is a landmark in
British history and terms of its way
it's dealt with the state of Israel
because up until now there's not been
unequivocal uh condemnation of violence
there's actually been a very sort of
wishy-washy condemnation of violence
this may be the beginning of a new cycle
of Peace we need to stop giving Terror
any possible window of of goodness right
we have to condemn it outright it's
outright like evil terrorists are
outright evil and they need to be told
that they need to be treated as such
Israeli security forces are still
hunting the West Bank for the gunman Leo
says he wants them to be tracked down
and brought to justice but doesn't hold
any hate towards them even though in a
moment of terrorism his family of seven
became a family of four
Aleister bunkel Sky News in ephrat in
the West Bank